imagine you're the National Security
adviser to the prime minister of Israel
what's your advice you take out their
command and control structure you take
out as much of their Resource as
possible they're not going to create a
buffer zone and then say okay well homas
is back we got the status quo status quo
is going to lead to more deaths on on
all sides we're going to have to have a
reckoning at some point with Iranian
regime because they are the reason why
we have this conflict right now the
White House has been talking about that
we need two-state solution well we read
the recent studies you know they've been
talking about two-state solution for
Generations Mike so first question right
uh is you were in the SI for a long time
and I think for people like us who don't
really know much about it a question
that never gets asked really is what is
the CIA and what does it do yeah I I
don't have a clue no we're still
confused over no no it's not uh the CIA
is Central Intelligence Agency right um
really hasn't been around that long came
out of World War II uh originally called
the office of strategic services and OSS
was created uh during World War I uh and
was essentially modeled after um the uh
British uh model for intelligence
operations right I mean that's kind of
where they they said okay well I guess
this is this is what we're going to need
to do so OSS kind of under the tutelage
of the British service during the course
of world
I began to develop this sense of okay
what we need is we need this other way
to protect National Security right and
that is a collection of intelligence all
over the world and that essentially is
the that that's the job of the CIA or
any intel service theoretically is to um
respond to Priority tasking from whoever
is in charge doesn't matter who's in the
white house right so whoever's in charge
they along with their National Security
team uh determine the priority tasking
and that priority tasking list is then
sent to the CIA and you you fan out all
your various resources whether it's
human sources or technical collection or
whatever and you respond to those
priority taskings with the overall goal
and it's the only objective is to
protect National
Security and the CIA certainly it seems
to me is no longer just collecting
intelligence it's also doing things
proactively taking people out some
people argue taking people out is it not
is it not doing that am I no I mean of
course during the global war on terror
yeah I mean there's no you know there's
no doubt about it and and that's you
know depending on what side of the fence
you people will argue with me but that's
a good thing I mean if you're taking out
high value targets who are involved in
Terrorist operations to kill not just us
Personnel or or Allies but you know
think of the the the countless Muslims
who were killed as a result of the
actions of a group like Isis or Al-Qaeda
or so I think um there was never just a
collection an analytical component to
OSS and then developing into CIA when
the Cold War hit um there's always been
the operational side to it so the
collection of intelligence and and then
you know you got to do something with it
but otherwise it's useless you collect
intelligence for the sake of it you put
it on a shelf over there there's no
point in having it right because all
intelligence for the most part has a
pretty short shelf life right meaning
the operational value of it you know is
is is pretty brief uh for the most part
so yeah it's um I mean it it was
interesting you you came out I'm not
going to disappeared on the historical
rabbit hole but you came out of World
War II Harry Truman the president at the
time said well thanks very much you know
to fellow named Bill Donovan who ran oss
the predecessor for CIA they you know
don't let the screen door hit your ass
on the way out and and um they shut it
down and then it didn't take very long
you know as the Soviets started
rampaging and doing what they're going
going to do for the US to realize well
we probably shouldn't have closed that
operation so they restarted it and then
became a CIA can I ask one more stupid
question we specialize in stupid
questions here but it's interesting to
explore the meanings of all these terms
you mentioned that the purpose of it is
National Security and that's a word get
that get a term that gets used often
what does National Security mean uh well
every nation acts in its own best
interest right I mean there okay maybe
you could imagine that the world's a
community of Nations and we're all
holding hands and you know un know corns
are flying out of our ass but that's not
the way the world works so um Every
Nation acts in its own best interest
every nation then determines what is in
its own best National Security interest
um typically defense of borders you know
defense of its economy whatever it may
be that Nation will set up its priority
tasking and then you know typically
works with its allies and in a you know
somewhat you know community of Nations I
suppose you could argue whether it's
NATO uh
OPEC is a good example I mean they band
together to protect their own interests
so Mike I'm my mother is from Venezuela
and there's uh there's some suspicion
shall I say about the CIA in Latin
America
no
shoted how much do you think that is
fair and warranted to have that
suspicion of the CIA and be distrustful
and how much of it do you think is
unfair um got trying to quantify that
look there's no there's no doubt that
some of it is warranted right
because you you
can't there's you can't be operating a
an intelligence organization with the
size of something like the CIA um or MI6
or any large Nation that's got well
resourced
capabilities um and not say that there's
going to be what's the best word for it
there's going to be a clash there's
going to be intrusions there's going to
be in in other nations activities right
because again we're all interconnected
so it's not as if you sit inside your
bubble right and say well we're
protecting our national security
interests and that never impacts anyone
else around right because other nations
are doing their own thing so I guess
that's a long rambling way to say some
of it's warranted some of it it's not it
is way above my pay grade to quantify
what the percentages on both sides would
be so what we have in Venezuela now as
as you know there's talk of a war with
Guyana yeah and you have Maduro who's
done a referendum yeah I want that yeah
I want 2third of Ghana yeah yeah so
exactly and all of a sudden he seems to
have discovered democracy when it
interesting which is quite interesting
so I well if you assume the referendum
is an actually you know clear and
transparent referendum but I I and I'm
sure the discovery of oil yeah in thekeo
had nothing to do with no of course no
of course not no of course not he's he's
a principled guy we know that so how
would the CIA approach this because
actually I don't think people are taking
this seriously enough this is a big deal
and it's happening right on the back
door of the United States right well
yeah it's it's it's a great question and
I agree with you I don't think it's not
that they're not taking seriously I
don't think anybody's paying attention
right people have very limited bandwidth
it seems right they get very sort of
ADHD on most issues so right now it's
all been Israel Hamas prior to that it
was Ukraine when 7 October kicked off
the conflict in the Middle East now you
couldn't find reporting on Ukraine for
weeks right it just so the fact that
nobody's looking over at Venezuela right
even
in within the US Administration and it's
in their own backyard right that that
doesn't surprise me in the least but
yeah you're absolutely right you're
talking about a move a referendum that
supposedly guarded what
95% positive response to seize 2third of
a neighboring country's territory that's
basically what it is that region is
about 2third of that size of that
country
um just in the region but more
importantly you know outside of the
region geopolitically that's that's a
major concern right but you get very
little attention paid to it so what is
the what's the role of a of a of of an
organization like the CIA in that I mean
if that's the question um well first and
foremost it's to be proactive and stay
ahead of the curve in terms of
understanding what's happening right
getting Insight so that you're not
surprised because that is part of
National Security is ensuring that the
leadership right whether it's the
president the Prime Minister Vladimir
Putin or whomever isn't surprised by
what's happening and so you have to be
ahead of the curve that means you're
collecting intelligence that means
you're gathering information from
whatever Source you may have that can
tell you what are the plans and
intentions right what's the
motivation um what are the intended
actions and that depending on the topic
is a really heavy lift right
so you look at um look at Iran as an
example understanding Iran's Ambitions
with its weapons program incredibly
heavy lift right very difficult limited
sources uh that you can potentially you
know tap into to understand that but
with Venezuela no it's it's a perfect
example look we we've missed the
boat many times um whether you're
talking about CIA or broadly us
Administration policy um over what's
happening in our own backyard Central
America um further south you know it's
it's an area that we tend to uh not so
much disregard as uh ignore right and
focusing on other concerns often times
you know recently terrorism obviously
but often times the Middle East um often
times our our you know activities
related to China Russia so right down
there right south of of the United
States tends to get um uh short shrift
right we don't I don't think tend to
focus enough attention or our best
resources or our best personnel and then
we get surprised you know somebody like
Chavez shows so um you know Maduro were
thinking like what the hell you know
what's what's with this cyclical shift
to the left on on a somewhat regular
basis it's because we don't pay
attention and you say we don't pay
attention and I think that you know
that's a very interesting point that you
raised there but what you're faced with
is political instability there of a huge
kind which is then going to impact the
US in a way I would argue and people say
I'm crazy when I say this on a similar
level to Israel Palestine for the United
States because Venezuela is backed by
Iran they're backed by China they're
backed by Russia this is a proxy war
isn't it yeah well it is essentially I
mean that's certainly how China is if
you just take them for that's how they
view it right we talk about Iran and
Ron's proxies you know and and currently
what they're doing to in a sense
escalate the conflict right you know the
US Administration is all spun up about
well we don't want to escalate the
conflict by you know upsetting or
targeting Iran's regime directly they're
already done it through their proxies
China looks at Venezuela as an example
and
and you know it's not as if they
approach the Venezuelan government with
offers of economic assistance because
they're gracious and benevolent right
that's it's so they're doing it
because they view this as a as a as a as
a I don't want to say a stronghold but
an opportunity right to create you know
um a foothold uh a a potential point of
disruption um
instability uh angst for the US
Administration all those things from the
from Chinese regime's point of view
those those are good things right so you
know look they're they're building a
military facility training facility uh
on behalf of the Cuban government right
are you that should be of concern um but
you know we've been again previous
administration or the the current and
the one before the Trump administration
were spun up about you know trying to
reestablish warmer relationships with
the Cuban regime and meanwhile the Cuban
regime is you know on the other side
they're dealing with China come on in
build this facility for us I mean that's
we don't we don't seem to multitask
sometimes very well right um and by that
I mean the the US administration at any
any given time not just this one not not
the Trump Administration not the Obama
Administration any Administration we
seem to have a hard time with the
concept that you know we want to do
right in the world you know I do believe
in a sense that the
US they they tend to of a lot of the
places that I've been and spent most of
my life overseas and some bizar places
they tend to uh have this um
this uh naive view sometimes that the
world is you know mirrored by our you
know the Western values right so and
everybody does that you know you mirror
your own values on other people the US
tends to do it in a in in a more or a
less pragmatic way because they
sometimes actually believe it oh you're
going to behave like we do right yeah we
go into Iraq or we go into Afghanistan
and we imagine somehow you know you're
going to get this boy you're going to
love our our whole idea of democracy and
20 years in a fistan and they didn't
know what the we were trying to
sell them right they had no idea after
all that time and so we could have known
that by looking at what the Soviets did
in Afghanistan we have all that
information about what the Soviets did
and how much trouble they had and how
many years they spent trying to get the
hell out of there for the same reasons
that we ended up trying to get that out
of there and eventually did so you know
we tend to do that um and that's a
problem you know so I I think and at the
same time then you know when you make
those mistakes when you mirror your
values and then then you don't get the
results cuz you've given them the party
hats and all the money and the resources
and they don't behave the way that you
want them to you know then you you you
spend this time trying to recalibrate
and it's it's it's a tough thing but
yeah Mike one of the things we've been
talking a lot on the show we recently
had the former prime minister of
Australia Tony Abbott and others talking
about the phrase that Vladimir Putin Xi
Jinping the leader of Iran the leaders
of many countries are now using which is
multi-polar World they keep talking
about this which seems to me like a code
for throwing America off the pedestal
essentially right challenging American
HED of money Etc uh and France has
brought up the issue with Venezuela what
is happening in the world at the moment
and why is it happening well you you're
right you're getting this this growing
effort a lot of it led by China frankly
um their Global initiative to create
this this concept of the global South
right we're going we're going to build
up you know this this this uh this
entity this this Global South operation
that is going to essentially the goal is
to supplant the us at the top I at the F
I'm simplifying this thing but but if
you imagine you got your your your uh
your ladder and right now and again I'm
not saying it is or isn't but this is
the Chinese regime's view the US sits on
top of that and they don't like that
they view themselves g x what I'm saying
I don't mean the Chinese people Chinese
culture history fantastic but the
Chinese regime led by
she views itself at the top of the food
chain right and they've got a a a plan
their Global Security initiative to get
there it's a blueprint and part of that
is to develop this world where you don't
have the us sitting up there I don't
think they're so much interested in a
multi-polar world they're interested in
a world where China replaces the US and
sits up top right and and creates this
influence and they're doing it through a
variety of of means and they've been
very successful ful as you pointed out
South America they've
spent over well over a decade and a half
right traveling around locking up Mining
rights and doing a variety of things
that they do to under their belt and
Road initiative to get to this point and
that that's their goal right and it's
not because they think the world will be
a better place because of it that's they
just want to sit up there and like you
said every country pursues its National
Security interest and National interest
and they're not doing it because it's in
the best interests of Venezuela or the
best interests of of uh the Democratic
Republic of Congo or wherever they've
been busy you know doing their their
business and and creating these
relationships mostly by handing out bags
of cash and so and then the bill comes
due and some of these countries are
starting to realize it's a problem
but look I you can you can you can make
an argument
that the world is a less chaotic place
when you have
a uh what's the word I'm looking for
bipolar no but when you have a a world
that
isn't um a multipolar I don't even know
if I understand what multipolar means
sometimes because I've heard different
definition definitions of it but when
you have a multi-polar world I think you
the potential the downside you maybe
there an upside downside is probably
more chaos well right this is what I
always think about because look I'm no
you know I hav't worked on the C I'm not
great expert but it just when I look at
what's happening in Mexico when you take
out a stable situation where one Cel is
dominant that doesn't usually end in
stability and peace and Kumbaya what
seems to happen is a power struggle
until the emergence of the next
hegemonic cartel and then you just go
around in these Circle so if you apply
that to the world it doesn't seem to me
that replacing the world as it is now
with a world which you have Russia China
the us all competing for that Top Dog
position that does not seem to me like a
more stable and secure world for
everybody involved I I don't I don't
think it is I mean you could Point not
just the cartels but we could look at
Tito you could look at Gaddafi you can
look at the I mean Saddam Hussein
right I mean um you know I'm not saying
better the devil you know but just
proving the point which is when you take
out what is a strong leader or situation
then you better be aware that what comes
in behind that could be chaotic and and
not particularly Pleasant Libya is a hot
mess right since Gaddafi left now before
Gaddafi got taken out he was kind of our
guy in terms of he had pledged his
support for fighting terrorism and all
of this and so theoretically he was a
and then there were other you know
reasons I suppose why you know some
countries were very keen to see Gaddafi
removed and he was and now nobody talks
about Libya but Libya is a disaster
right it's a complete disaster slave
markets everywhere it's it's it's
terrible um you know I so I think yes I
think there's there's there is that
problem but um again I get it you you
people look around at at a uh situation
where you know the US sits on top of the
of the food chain um people you know
complain well they're acting as the
policeman of the of the world um
imposing their you know views on things
and and you know okay fine china sits
over here and goes well that's what we
want it's not like it's not like they're
upset because you know not enough voices
are heard they they're just simp so
that's fine I I get why people complain
about whoever's at the top you know at
that particular moment in time but don't
be unrealistic about why someone else is
complaining about it right they're not
doing it because they feel as if well we
should all have more of a say in things
they want more of a say in things and
the obvious question is given given uh
the US support for Ukraine given the US
obvious support for Israel uh given the
US's huge level of indebtedness of its
own irrespective of those conflicts too
how well positioned is America to
actually fight off these CH these very
serious challenges right yeah it's a
problem because you're talking I mean
look at you're talking about with Israel
you know the the concern was opening up
a multi front War right well you know
the US is is facing these these various
fronts um in a much more serious way
like I can remember when our biggest
issue was um Haiti um the the Balkan
crisis which was a real problem but you
look at the scale of it now and you look
at you know the the theater War
involving Ukraine and Russia you look at
the the Middle East now the Middle East
is you can argue okay well it's just
more of the same I suppose I've heard
this you people say ah it's you know
it's always a problem over there you
think what so okay uh if you want to
dismiss it that way but it is and it and
they're having discussions in in the
states in Washington DC up on Capitol
Hill uh at this very moment talking
about what can we and can we not do
there is a growing sense that with
Ukraine part of this is obviously based
on domestic politics that you know
enough's enough maybe you know maybe
that money needs to be brought back and
and spent at home um maybe you know
there's there's not uh the appetite you
know that people thought at the outbreak
when during the it's been almost two
years since uh Putin moved in in a big
way but I think you know we had people
out on the streets waving Ukraine Flags
everybody's you know free Ukraine
everybody's got bumper stickers um flags
on their their front
porches and it's not been quite 2 years
and there's a fair amount of fatigue
right M which is um I think surprising
to a lot of people but and also the
attention because you know we have short
attention spans everyone's now focused
on Israel do you think it's also because
the ukrainians aren't winning oh sure if
the ukrainians were kicking ass I don't
think you'd have War exhaustion in this
way yeah I agree with you 100% I there's
no doubt about it um the the emotions
were running High um leading into the
counter offensive you know at the
beginning of Summer um and and you're
right if they had made inroads if they
had you know made their
way as maybe even to their own borders
again uh on the East um sure we wouldn't
be having the same conversation there
wouldn't there wouldn't be this sense of
well maybe enough's enough you know but
I think look you have to be pragmatic
right and and again this is where I
think sometimes you know the US can miss
the boat a little bit and they they
sometimes they catch up for domestic uh
political reasons and in this case we
got a 2024 election coming up and I
think the current White House looks
around and thinks okay well what's you
know where's the wind blowing as far as
the voters go right do they have the
stomach to continue putting billions and
billions of dollars into Ukraine um just
like with Israel you know where where
where are the winds blowing and the
current Administration looks out there
and sees protests in the street you know
related to to uh free Palestine or from
the river to to the Sea and they look at
the Arab American voters they look at
the youth voters and they you know
suddenly it goes from okay unequivocal
support to Israel to yes but we have to
be very very careful here and you have
to be very careful about how you you
know conduct your operations on M and we
have to look for a a a truce and they're
playing both sides right and and that's
a strange place to
be we'll be back with our guests in a
minute but first if you're looking for
the perfect Christmas present for the
man in your life then look no further
than this incredible offer from
manscaped the folks over at manscaped
have been working night and day to bring
you a below the waste grooming
experience like none other with their
brand new performance package 5.0 Ultra
we've been working with manscape for 2
years now and if like me you're a young
man about town and I am young shut it
and you want to impress the ladies or
gents then I recommend you take a look
at manscape to level up your grooming
game and boost your confidence and
there's no better way to start than with
the brand new performance package 5.0
Ultra inside the package you'll find the
best trimmer on the market the lawn
mower 5.0 Ultra this is manscaped fifth
generation trimmer and features two
interchangeable skin safe blade heads
there's a standard head for taking a
little off the top and a new foil blade
for you to go smooth wherever your heart
desires also inside this package you get
the weed whacker 2.0 ear and nose hair
trimmer CR preserver ball deodorant crop
Soo the toner and that's not it you also
get the incredibly comfortable manscape
boxers 2.0 plus their newest travel bag
get 20% off and free shipping with the
code trigger 20 at manscape.com that's
20% off plus free shipping with a code
trigger2 manscaped.com
manscaped trim your ches tickles with
the besticles they made me say that yeah
it's a strange Place sometimes when you
think that your foreign policy is driven
by domestic political concerns Ian I'm
not sure that that's the best route to
go um because again you define your
National Security interests those should
be free of your own domestic political
interests I would think but I'm not a
politician so what the hell do I know
Mike we we're looking at this situation
around the world we're seeing these wars
potentially springing up or springing up
you go how much is this the
responsibility of the Biden government
how much of this is these leaders
looking at Biden and going yeah now's
our time yeah
um yeah I I I I try not to be too
political right I mean I you know one of
the things that I always tried to
imagine whether it's true or not it's
suppos but you know you do based on your
own experience the CIA tends to be a uh
an
apolitical uh operation M at the at the
operational level you know again you've
got a director who has some you know
he's he's got his own relationship with
the president um but if you're just you
know somebody within CIA operations you
don't believe me spend any time sitting
around chatting about politics that you
don't care and you and ideally I've seen
and I've been in a lot of countries
where you have holesale change every
time there's a change in the the
government and they just clear out that
particular uh Intel operation law
enforcement and bring in their own
people that is a terrible place to be so
to the degree that it can be you need to
do everything possible to ensure that
your Intel operations are apolitical and
again realizing it's a human endeavor so
you're never got to get down to
completely apolitical but as far
as you know is the current turmoil the
result of people looking at Joe Biden
and saying well he and his team seem a
little bit weak so maybe now is the is
the time to engage in
this um I think every Administration
gets tested right Joe Biden is a known
quantity right these these these various
leaders out there they they they've seen
him for 50 years and in one way or
another or their personnel have seen
them their Intel operations have been
assessing politicians for all this time
so they've had 50 years to look at
everything about Joe Biden so it's not
as if in the past couple of years they
thought Let's test him they kind of knew
what they were getting right and he came
in and I think certainly if we just kind
of look around the the the world Iran
has certainly made the calculation that
they're not dealing with a strong leader
right they're not dealing with somebody
who they can't quite read right and by
that I mean you could go back to uh
Ronald Reagan right one of the things
that the Soviets had a problem with with
in terms of profiling and assessment was
they really weren't sure exactly how
aggressive he was going to be at any
given moment they didn't know because
they they felt as if he was capable of
walking in to NORAD and saying well
let's let those missiles fly and that
tends to keep people a little bit more
Garden on the back foot so Iran's made
the same calculation I think in a
different way with with the Biden team
in part because the Biden team came out
at the very beginning and said we want
we want to bring in a a different
mindset we want to have a warm
relationship with well we want to have a
relationship with Iran um they took
their foot off the sanctions pedal right
and they put in place in their various
positions that are Iran forward leading
whether the state department or the
Pentagon or elsewhere they put in people
who had a appeasement in mind who had
you know let's let's get rid of this
maximum pressure approach that was
previously used with the Iranian regime
and let's let's call it a new day the
Irani rashim doesn't want a new day
every time you put your hand out to
shake their hand they smack it away
right I mean that's that's a track
record that they have so I think yes the
chaos now that you're seeing in the
Middle East cuz
Hamas wouldn't exist without Iran
Hezbollah wouldn't exist without Iran
the hotti militants that are launching
missiles into the Red Sea they wouldn't
exist without Iranian support and
training and and funding resources
so uh
what they're doing now is based on their
assessment that they're dealing with a
weak White House right um did Putin make
the same
calculation uh that one I that almost
feels to me like I'm just like wasting
your time by speculating way too much I
I I don't know but I will say there's
nothing really surprising about the
Biden White House you know or secretary
Anthony Lincoln or or any of them so I
don't think they had a hard time reading
what their response would be um they
looked at Obama and Obama you know had
laid down a couple of red lines in the
past when he was president and and
apparently they weren't actually red
lines or lines in the sand because he
didn't take any action I think they look
at that sort of thing and think okay
well Biden is part of that same mindset
um China I think is is a little bit
different they play a much longer game I
don't think they look in terms of we're
going to take advantage of a 2year three
foure time frame I mean they're way down
the road right so I don't think they
look at Biden and think Okay now what's
our move on Taiwan right and that's a
much longer runway for them so I don't
know it's it's a it's a great question I
don't think I gave you much of an answer
no I think it was a very good answer and
I think it was a very honest answer Mike
you know uh I find it surprising and
look maybe I get this wrong and please
correct me that the American government
have been giving Iran money oh sure yeah
yeah yeah yeah recently yeah yeah yeah
that's that's insane well you would you
could argue that there's no reason for
it right now because they haven't done
anything in a sense to deserve it but
it's part of this idea that they've been
unfreezing assets so they they unfroze a
while back six billion that really hit
the headlines right they because I think
the Republicans were they saw you know
blood in the water and thought okay this
is an opportunity to make some hay here
but in reality the Biden
administration's actions had been giving
the Iranian regime much more money than
that because they had again eased on the
sanctions uh allowing Iran to realize
much greater revenues from their oil um
and but they they unfroze six billion as
an example of assets and
um their idea their concept uh which is
I think is extremely flawed was that we
are just giving this to them it's their
money anyway from their old oil proceeds
but we froze it you know and and and
they're saying it's only to be used for
humanitarian purposes and they did the
same with another tranch of money that
they just uh unfroze 1010
billion uh it's only for humanitarian
purposes
well I a the US government has a hard
time keeping track of its own money
right so so the idea that they're going
to somehow monitor this stack of cash
right that that they've now uh
unlocked is absurd but also money's
fungible so you know if you tell me that
you're now giving me $10 billion but you
can only use it for medicine or to build
another school well that's great okay
that's what I'll use it for but I'm
going to take this other 10 billion that
I got sitting over here in my reserves
and now I'm going to spend that on more
drones and missiles for the hotti
militants to you know spend some time
up the Red Sea and creating more
of the chaos that I I want to create
because you know instability from their
perspective is is good it keeps it it
keeps distance from that what they don't
want which is a stable Middle East you
get a stable Middle East by implication
that means Israel has a right to exist
right if the Saudis make that deal and
normalize relationships are you kidding
me the Iranian regime doesn't want that
so whatever they do is is designed to
meet that ultimate objective which is
the destruction of Israel but I guess
going back to the money the idea that
the US Administration could stand in
front of the cameras and tell the
American public or Congress that yeah
you know we're monitoring it only used
for humanitarian purposes it's just
either they think that the American
people are incredibly stupid right or
the American people are really stupid
and they and they know something and
they just they're just doing the obvious
so anyway uh yeah they are giving of
money and M you you mentioned Israel
Palestine I think I think we' really
like to talk about that a little bit the
obvious question for me is imagine
you're the National Security adviser to
the prime minister of Israel it's octo
the morning of October
8th what's your advice what how do we
respond what do we do well I think
a your your first response is what they
did and and to me that makes perfect
sense you have to destroy this entity
you have to you have to remove Hamas can
you is that possible well no and and
that's the next part of the calculation
which they've now come around to which
is you can't do that right
counterterrorism is is not a uh zero
some game you can't reduce the risk down
to zero never will happen right you
mitigate and you you you do what you can
right um doesn't mean that you don't
take out targets I mean that's a that's
a you know in counterterrorism anyway I
don't want to sound mercenary and people
go oh my God that's terrible well that's
great but and when we live in that
wonderful world where everybody gets
along fine you know don't do it but uh
people don't act in in other people's
best interest so when you're talking
about counterterrorism um I do get it if
you if their initial response it was a
motive it was anger it was despair it
was anguish it was all these things were
going to destroy Hamas right
and and the concept is is right but it's
what they don't mean is is in reality
right so what you want to do is you
degrade the structure of Hamas so much
that you've mitigated the risk down to
as much as possible which is not going
to be zero right because they've got a
bottomless well of potential recruits it
seems on the fighter level you take out
their command and control structure you
take out as much of their Resource as
possible Iran will keep filtering it in
right um but that's what you do now the
problem and they knew this was going to
be a problem right at the outset was the
narrative and the narrative turned
remarkably quickly given how brutal 7
October was the narrative turned
amazingly quickly to it's Israel's fault
because look at all these dead
Palestinians well Hamas knows exactly
what they're getting Hamas has been in
charge I you know sometimes you talk to
these young people that are out on the
college campuses and they're like well
you know you got to get the Israelis out
of Gaza you think well how long have
they been there and they've been oh you
know ever since Israel's been a state
and you think okay well look not not to
you know pick too fine a point here but
they they handed
Gaza over to Hamas right Hamas kicked
fat out and what was that 06 I guess 06
and Hamas has done nothing in that
intern period to now to better the lives
of the Palestinian citizens in fact
they've taken most of the money that was
funneled by Nos and governments to
improve the lives of Palestinians
right and they've pocketed it or used it
for their own terrorist purposes right
so billions of dollars have just been
funneled away from the people on the
ground right then people go well they
voted Hamas in okay well okay fine but
it's kind of like the referendum on K I
don't know was the referendum honest Was
the vote honest who knows I mean there
is very high levels of support for Hamas
and Gaza now there are certainly and I
would say that before and I would also
argue that it it's not in your own best
interest to say you don't support Hamas
so you know I I it's like any poll
numbers I don't trust a lot of poll
numbers the us or or UK or anywhere
right so I'm I give this example chiao
chesco had a 93% approval rating the day
before he was arrested and executed
right the 7% are very powerful mik so um
I suppose Mike what I'm getting at is it
seemed to me with the October 7th attack
Israel was in a position I forget what
it's called in chess where every move
you make makes you lose it seems like
that to me you respond you're the evil
bad guy killing innocent palestin kids
you don't respond you've just had you're
911 and you you're not doing anything
right um you want to destroy herass but
actually you can't right so what's the
what is the play here well the play the
play is what is going to happen which is
they going to hit a point where they
feel as if they've done what they can um
and they balance that with the
international pressure which is enormous
right and rightly so you don't want and
they understand this it's it's it's
insane to me sometimes when people go
well they just don't have a disre they
have no regard for life well yeah of
course yes they do right and and people
won't believe that my personal
experience with you know with the IDF
and and operations and is they have a
great concern in part because they know
what it means on the world stage right
and in part because they just they
they're not a Hamas Hamas embeds
themselves with the civilians because
they know they're going to get dead
civilians because they know that's going
to help their narrative right I mean
it's
just you know I'm not going to be pushed
off of that believe anyway and so they
have no regard it's like saying Isis had
regard for you know the the the the
people of of Iraq or Al-Qaeda had regard
for they
drive bomb Laden vehicles in the middle
of a market they don't care about
casualties right it's not their their
point for being so with Israel they've
got to they've got to find that point I
think they've already assessed it and
made that decision look they're already
talking to the Saudis and you know
Egyptians and Jordanian government um
about the plan the security plan um for
Gaza once the conflict ends they're
talking about a buffer zone along the
border an increased buffer zone along
the border that implies that they
understand they're not going to be able
to get rid of Hamas right so that Hamas
can't do what they did on 7th October
but in implies that they understand this
idea that they're going to completely
destroy
Hamas is probably not going to happen
the question then to backfill that is is
well what happens to Gaza who governs
Gaza right um the US administration had
a relatively simplistic answer you know
they've been pushing this about well we
get Mahmud abas from the West Bank you
know they'll go back in you know point
being is Hamas kicked out F Hamas kicked
out you know that that organization
that's why they ended up in the West
Bank and you had this split situation
with Hamas and Gaza people really don't
have much time for mmud abas right
so that's probably not a realistic thing
but what does it mean Hamas cannot
remain governing in Gaza I don't think
that's going that's not going to happen
so they're not going to create a buffer
zone and then say okay well homas is
back we got the status quo status quo is
going to lead to more deaths on on all
sides and more instability and you might
feel righteous about calling for a
ceasefire right now right but until you
get you know some plan in place that
says this is what we're going and it's
not the status quo
you're just basically kicking the can
down the road so you feel righteous
about yourself because you can go out on
the campuses and protest for you know a
ceasefire um Hamas has already clearly
stated they're going to keep doing it
right 7 October I mean they've said it
repeatedly sin War has been very clear
and it's probably a good thing for
people to take them at their word based
on what they've done so Mike the thing
that I find frustrating when we talk
about Israel Palestine is and we've
already touched on this point before we
look at these people like amas through
Western eyes and they think that they
think like us when the reality is they
look at the world a little bit
differently don't
they just just a little look um yeah and
that is and that's an incredibly
important part this the the CIA one of
your toughest jobs is to um is to
understand that that that if you're
because again imagine it's not an easy
sales job right trying to convince say a
Russian Colonel or a you know member of
the foreign Ministry in in Russia or
wherever to uh provide information that
will benefit the west and could likely
end up to that individual's death and
that's a tough cell so you have to be
deep into the psyche of whoever you're
talking to you have to really understand
what their mindset is and terrorists
it's the same way because you're still
trying to collect Intel right you're
still looking for sources of information
you want hey if you can get a source
inside hamasa alamba gate great right so
it's not as if you don't do the same
Intel collection effort or like with a
cartel whatever it may be um so that's
that's an incredibly important part of
it we don't understand the West I mean
doesn't understand the brutality right
we don't understand the disregard for
for human life for value values that we
hold dear and
so you're right we imagine uh scenarios
or we game out potential attack
scenarios how do we defend ourselves
against these things and and sometimes
you it's a very difficult process
because you you can't imagine the the
the lack of regard that um that some of
these organizations have some of these
people have for for human life it's just
we can't fa it it's not part of our our
our abilities we can't for whatever
reason right we we think we can you know
because we've seen the news and we but
ultimately at the end of the day it is a
real problem it's a flaw that we have in
the whole process of assessment of
recruitment of of sources of
understanding potential attack plans and
scenarios of motivations plans and
intentions it's a real it's it's a real
problem you've
outlined we'll be back with our guests
in a minute but first do you remember
the the Canadian trucker protest in 2022
where thousands of Canadians came out to
protest covid restrictions and vaccine
mandates now these protests lasted for
weeks and the people out on the streets
needed funds as any Grassroots protest
would so people set up online
crowdfunding campaigns which rais
millions of dollars incredible but once
the Canadian authorities had started to
criticize the crowdfunding platforms
ramping up pressure to close the
campaigns it didn't take long for the
biggest crowdfunding platform the one
we've all heard of to completely
capitulate and shut the campaigns down
now this is where our partners give send
go come in they stepped in when the
other platforms backed off and raised
millions of dollars for the truckers
when they were criticized and dragged
through the Canadian courts GFS and go
said it respected diverse views and
believed hope and freedom are values
worth fighting for this is why we're
proud to partner with gifs and go so if
you need to crowdfund for whatever means
the most to you then don't go to the big
Tech platforms we recommend you do it on
giv Sendo starting a campaign on give
send go is easy and intuitive go to gend
go.com today that's gend go.com to start
raising money for whatever is important
to you and now back to the
interview to me it's this utopian way of
seeing the world which is lovely in a
way but it's you know quite demented as
well that you know you're going to sit
down with Hamas or you're going to sit
down with Nicolas Maduro and you know
and he's going to be you know what
you're right I've just seen it you're
right yeah you got it yeah you got it
don't know why I didn't think about this
yeah you just you just you know we
watched this Disney film together and
all of a sudden you know what it's it's
really important that we treat everybody
as equal The Bear Necessities yeah yeah
no I it's um look you need to have hope
in the world right you want to think you
want to imagine that things get better
that that people think that way and and
and that's a good thing um but I can
only talk from personal experience and
you know I tend to be pretty cynical
about about things in part in part
because you see the worst of people out
there right and
um and so while you want to imagine that
you can get to a place where there's
this this peaceful world and everybody's
operating together and we're all
concerned about the common good you know
you've got a responsibility again going
back to the original thoughts about
National Security and National Security
interest first responsibility protect
your you know your citizens your your
your population your people um so being
naive or being hopeful hope is not
necessarily or or feelings right or the
idea of being righteous it's not a good
way to direct your your your your
planning for as far as National Security
interests Homeland defense whatever it
may may be um and that if that makes you
cynical so be it but again I I I look
around and I I think sometimes we get
caught short
because we um it's not just about
mirroring values right it's it's it's
sometimes it's deeper than that we
genuinely um imagine
that taking the high road right is is
somehow going to force others or lead
others to do the same and it never it
never happens and certainly it won't
happen with a group like Hamas or or the
Iranian regime look the you know again I
go back to the same thing at some point
the us is going to have to deal with the
Iranian regime or the the US and and
allies you know it's going to take that
it's going to take a very strong
coalition to do this um and I don't mean
militarily but we're going to have to
have a reckoning at some point with
Iranian regime because they are the
reason why we have this conflict right
now and they have been the reason in the
past and they will be in the future as
long as they are allowed to IM imagine
that they can continue to disrupt and
and and pursue their dream of of the
destruction of
Israel Mike neither France have anything
like the expertise that you bring to
this conversation but the one thing I
think the reason people sometimes listen
to what we say about these things is he
mentioned his mother family from
Venezuela I was born in Russia grew up
in the Soviet Union so this idea that
Western people have about people in
other parts of the world being all nice
and sweet
friendly but you know what we spend more
and more time in America now when I go
to America it kind ofes sense to me
because Americans are genuinely from my
experience like really nice people
they're kind of very friendly and uh
helpful and collaborative and so I think
it's hard for people in the US to
imagine that there are parts of the
world where people don't think about the
world in that way yeah uh do you did you
have to have some kind of like anti-
mirroring training as part of your C
thing or you just land in Baghdad and
you're like after 3 days you kind of got
it all sused out okay yeah you're there
and you go like well this is um
so yeah part of it I with the US I
think um I part part of it a space issue
by that I mean size issue right you've
got the luxury of of of all this land
mass right and
so while it's not an isolationist place
right in a sense it is we
it's constantly inward looking right and
so you know a lot of problems just seem
a long ways away and and that allows you
I think to be whether it's nicer maybe
it's naive uh whatever the word is it
you have that benefit because of
distance and size right and um it's the
same reason why people make fun of
Americans for so few of them having
passports you don't need a passport in
America yeah you everything you want to
go skiing go skiing you want to go to
the beach go to the beach you want to
live in the city live in the city you
want to go to the desert go to desert
yeah and it's and so and that's always
my response too is look have you have
you been there I mean it's it's got its
benefits now it's got its drawbacks too
because yeah you know the the variety is
is amazing when you start traveling
around the world and tell you what you
don't have in America and actually it's
really important the one thing you don't
have is history and I think that's one
of the reasons that American foreign
policy and just general people sometimes
you know they haven't seen 2,000 years
of the same mistake being made over and
over right in their buildings in their
monuments in their history books so it's
easier to think in a more idealistic way
perhaps which can be a strength but I
also think it can be a weakness as you
alluding to I think that's I think
that's right um we have a short-term
view in part because it's a short
history over there right and um in part
because we just we just everyone seems
to have ADHD but um they're certainly
all taking the medication for it let's
put it that way so it's I think it's
just a it's an interesting idea but I
think I mean where where does that what
does that lead to I mean the
the the the problem I think that's
facing the us right now is not so much
outside our borders right I mean that's
a problem right that obviously goes
without saying but um our political
system right now is really divisive and
it's if you in talking about how little
history we've got it's incredible that
we've gotten that to this point in such
a short period of time right uh it's
two-party system and it is like trench
warfare right now yeah nobody's talking
to the on the other side there's nobody
living in the middle you know and um so
that is contributing I think to some of
the problems that we're facing right uh
both domestically certainly and then
outside the country because it impacts
the way that any Administration comes in
and Views foreign policy um and because
they're so focused on how dysfunctional
the internal politics is right now and
and also there's a tremendous amount of
self-interest there's self-interest with
every politician everywhere around the
world but um in the US we have Senators
who can you know maintain their job as a
senator
for you know 42 years uh you know 50
years their entire career they can have
done nothing else except be a politician
and that's a I think it's a real problem
but that's not a topic for today so and
it's that division because a nation
divided is going to be weaker M yeah
absolutely no absolutely and you tend to
get then you'll get these cataclysmic
events you know 911 whatever it may be
draws everyone together that's that's
kind of standard human behavior you have
that one and that's you know Putin's
very good at that Putin is extremely
good and has been good at creating the
outside threat you know whenever he's
faced with internal turmoil or or
potential political descent create an
outside threat rally the people around
it and he's been extremely good about
that she and China you know does the
same thing essentially um although he's
got problems from an economic
perspective I think that that we are
still struggling to understand I think
and and that's going to be important
because that speaks to his ability to
stay in power um so Mike we want to ask
you some questions from our supporters
so we'll we'll head on over uh there in
a second but before we let you go uh we
always ask the final question question
before we do though I just wanted to ask
I mean it feels like I think to a lot of
people the world is kind of on fire at
the moment do you think is your
shortterm prognosis that it's going to
get better or is it's going to get
worse um I think it's going to get
better and I'll tell you why really wow
I think it's going to get I know right
you spent too much time in America you
may be born here but you're not British
don't that's right it's it's it's
and it's going to get more uh I
don't think it's a word but I just made
it up uh you think it's going to get
better and here's why I say that okay is
because I think that um there will be a
negotiated settlement in
Ukraine um in part because uh there is
this fatigue uh in the EU as well
obviously in the US in terms of
resources um Putin was counting on that
I think he he knew you know that that
this got drawn out
that this would happen I think that was
their assessment he hasn't made a lot of
right calculations about this war but I
think that was probably one of those
that he intuitively understood that the
US would not be you know uh politically
would not have the will for a long
period of time zilinsky I think will'll
see that zin's got his own internal
political issues right now um and that's
going to be a serious problem if they
don't get that pulled together
right if they if he starts you know you
start seeing these these fractures and
criticism and a lot of nitpicking and
all these and arguments that's going to
do nothing to sh up support you know
from allies so I think the the the
solution will be that they will come to
a negotiated s on that
will unfortunately kind of leave things
looking the way that they were at the
outset um you know if anything I think
maybe the the Russians will end up with
a little bit more land I'm not saying
this is a good result I'm just saying
that that's what I think is going to be
the result um is all M I think is uh
also I know it doesn't look like it
right now but I think it's winding down
um because again I think they've they've
made that decision the toughest part is
going to be who governs right that's
going to be the biggest issue right it's
not going to be the biggest issue is not
going to be when do we pull troops out
of Gaza right and and what backfield
said it's going to be what's the longer
term situation they're governing people
talk about we a two-state solution the
White House has been talking about that
we need a two-state solution well read
the recent studies read the recent you
know case history on this and you know
they've been talking about a two-state
solution for Generations right 48 you
know and then they talked about it 93
they talked about 03 talked about in 14
never happens right but somebody's got
to come up with a solution but I'm what
I'm saying is the conflict itself I
think will wind down um and and again if
it if it ends up in just the status quo
and Hamas remains as sort of a governing
entity in Gaza I think then it'll kick
off again and we'll have problems and
and and but if they can solve that
problem I think we're we're in better
shape um x i I don't think you're
looking at a at a neartime move on
Taiwan in anyway I think that that will
be a soft move I don't think you you
know we imagine that he's going to like
bring the ships in and you know and drop
in troops and suddenly they take over
Taiwan I I don't think that is the way
that they're planning this out right I
think you look at Hong Kong and how they
did Hong Kong and I think that that's
more of the approach they're looking at
with Taiwan on a a soft slow
envelopment U of of the
society so yeah I think will we always
have problems of course we I'm not don't
go me wrong we don't know where the next
ship Storm's going to come from but
that's why you have Intel Services
theoretically to be out there looking
for those next crises not just in the
one that's in front of you right we did
that with terrorism for a while right we
made that mistake right you respond you
get a terrorist attack next thing you
know you're responding by by building in
physical protocols to deal with that
previous attack rather than what that
next one might look like right so the
the the key to you know Intel Services
is you've got to be imagining what is
the next Crisis what's the next Hotpot
what's the next problem and that's what
they spend all their time trying to
do but yeah you know as bizarre as it
sounds I I I'm a somewhat I'm a cynic
but I'm a somewhat hopeful person too
and uh and I also think it's a pretty
resilient world that we live in so
um you know at some point we'll you know
I I'll be proven wrong but then you can
have me back and I'll say yeah I
that one up Mike final question what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that we really should
be God that's a hell of a question um we
ask schol I guess that one that same one
yeah oh I bet some people have given
really good answers too some yeah some
okay well this won't be one of those
times um yeah I I think uh for me and
again this will this will be boring but
I think the one thing that we need to be
focused on that we're not focused on
right now I mean some some people are
but it's a small group uh would be the
uh the
underlying uh strength of the economy in
China right uh second largest economy in
the world um and we've been kind of
kicking that can down the road willing
to look the other way as they present us
with three or four or five different
sets of books you know in terms of their
economy um there are a lot of problems
they've been having issues she has
actually been getting some push back
from party elders and over the course of
the past year very upset about the
economy very concerned about what does
that mean it means population unrest so
one thing that they worry about is
losing control of the population um
again we have to imagine
because you know this is where we put
our Western values on there and go well
I mean sure of course they'll get out in
the streets and they'll protest and
everything well it's not really they've
tried that didn't work out didn't work
out yeah didn't work out very well at
all um and uh but I think that that is
the thing that people should be focused
on because so much of of what goes on
globally we're very interconnected right
in terms of economics which drives a lot
of other issues and concerns and
conflicts that's the thing that I think
people need to focus a little bit more
on um look you know not that we're going
to get that transparency we still don't
know what the hell happened as far as Co
goes cuz the Chinese regime has failed
to be transparent in any way and the
world has failed to demand answers as
opposed to just asking and then giving
them a free pass right so we don't know
we're going to have another pandemic
there's no doubt about it um we'd be
better positioned to mitigate the risks
of the next pandemic if we had
transparency from the Chinese regime
over what actually happened there right
but we don't so anyway I guess my point
there is understanding the underlying
problems with their economy will be no
easier right because it's it's it's very
hard to to gather that sort of
information um but it's something that
people should look at perfect thank you
very much sure thanks for coming on no
thank
you what do you think of this latest
news about the 20 to 40e infiltration of
the US government by a Cuban spy and
what the potential consequences of such
an
infiltration
[Music]